bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france une opération militaire qui a été
mise à mal avec la crise du cornât virus
quel est l'enjeu
notamment après les critiques des
manuels macron sur la mort cérébrale de
l'otan je crois qu'il faut revenir un
fonctionnement normal de l'otan qui est
de s'entraîner en permanence pour tester
notamment le déploiement américain en
europe mais pas uniquement mais aussi
travailler avec les autres forces
otanienne ce que vous avez présenté là
cet exercice qui regroupe des dizaines
de milliers de soldats aujourd'hui est
complètement caduque
c'est un exercice aujourd'hui notamment
mois dernier qui a regroupé quelques
milliers d'hommes
parce que l'aco vie 19 est passée par là
voilà donc nous sommes dans une logique
d'entraînement et les questions
politiques évoquées par macron sont
complètement à différencier il ya d'un
côté la dimension militaire doit
s'entraîner et d'autres côté la
dimension politique on doit améliorer d
organisation et le fonctionnement des
organisations
alors après des années de réductions
d'effectifs militaires ce déploiement
exceptionnel reflète le bouleversement
stratégique provoqué par le rattachement
de la crimée par la russie en 2014 selon
un général américain
est-ce que selon vous cet exercice vise
clairement moscou alors effectivement un
général américain commandant les forces
américaines en europe l'a évoqué oui
donc très bien maintenant la réalité est
tout autre
certes l'otan s'entraîne il faut je
dirais entre guillemets un an et demi
d'exercice les mines d'exercice en
l'occurrence aujourd'hui c'est la russe
qui je ne suis pas certain que si dans
ces exercices câble en a fait quelques a
notamment récemment avec beaucoup plus
d'effectifs ne désigne pas non plus un
ennemi qui serait peut-être de l'otan je
n'en sais rien mais dans tous les cas il
faut bien dissocier l'entraînement où il
faut et quelque chose d'à peu près
concret c'est je veux pas dire qu'on va
faire la guerre demain mais sans traîner
mérite un ennemi d'exercice en
l'occurrence c'est vrai on évoque la
russie aujourd'hui mais il faut pas non
plus dramatiser
alors les européennes tempère aller voc
l'engagement fort des états unis envers
l'otan pour la liberté la sécurité de
l'europe en situation est que cela
reflète aussi des relations entre les
états unis et l'union européenne
nous avons un problème avec les états
unis aujourd'hui
peut-être pas avec les états unis mais
avec les présidents trump le président
un trump à une volonté manifeste de
faire du bizness par notamment l'achat
et la vente d'armements aussi que les
forces américaines en europe lui coûte
moins cher et que les européens payent
plus ça c'est un premier point
le deuxième point il ya aussi des
relations particulières entre plaisant
entre eux et n'ont pas forcément les
états unis et angela merkel
c'est pourquoi il a été annoncé il ya
quelques semaines le départ de douze
mille américains de l'allemagne dont une
partie pourrait sous une forme
temporaire est présente en pologne
voilà donc c'est un peu le contexte
aujourd'hui puis un troisième point
peut-être c'est aussi des pressions
économiques que puisque on pourrait
aussi parler des pressions sur
l'allemagne face à un hors stream 2 qui
convoie du gaz russe vers l'europe
donc un ensemble de problèmes où il ya
une question militaire une question
politique est une question économique
est alors au plan sanitaire qu'est ce
qui doit se passer un très concrètement
lors de cet exercice on évoque à un gros
défi logistique pour les équipes
militaires à tout à fait jeu il ya 6000
e américain qui doit venir des états
unis avec du matériel lourd
quel que soit le payer c'est un travail
énorme et c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin
d'entraînement la logistique et le
transport des troupes d'une part et du
matériel d'autre part impose une
excellente organisation
rappelons nous quand même eisenhower
quand il a reconquis l'europe je dirais
a quand même considéré qu' on n'allait
jamais aussi loin que là où l'âge
logistique pouvait aller s'il n'y a pas
de logistique
il n'y a pas de déploiement de tout
efficaces et l'armée peu une armée peut
perdre voilà donc ces faits est un vrai
défi logistique est essentielle pour
entraîner les trous à faire face et à se
projeter rapidement pour montrer une
détermination politique et militaire
face à une potentielle agression est
alors au défi au delà des défis
logistiques est ce que ce type
d'opération peut être dangereuse est ce
qu'il ya des risques non ya pas de
risque d'abord parce que les hommes
politiques se soit vladimir poutine ou
le président un train pour les le
président macro ont des relations
fréquentes
tout est fait pour éviter tout incident
nous
dans des exercices ensuite il y a quand
même des mesures de sécurité qui ont été
définies à la fin de la guerre froide
justement pour assurer je dirais la
mauvaise qu'il n'y ait pas de mauvaises
interprétations du déploiement de force
toute force plus de 9000 hommes par
exemple plus de 250 chars doit faire
l'objet d'une notification 42 jours
avant le dépouillement des forces là
nous n'en sommes pas là donc voilà donc
et des mesures de confiance comme on les
appelle en 1990 1991 ou on communique à
ceux qui pourraient se sentir agressés
attention c'est un exercice
voilà ce qu'on met sur le terrain et
d'ailleurs vous pourriez vérifier la
réalité de ce que nous faisons merci
d'avancé avec la france achevant si je
rappelle que vous êtes un général de
brigade et expert en géostratégie